one announces special commercial-free
benefit concert you can see across all
Fox programming the I Heart living room
concert for America airs this Sunday at
9 p.m. Eastern is hosted by Elton John
no future performances from Alicia Keys
Billy Isle ish when I carry Tim McGraw
and many more
again that's this Sunday 9 p.m. Eastern
to any television station with the name
Fox in it and that would include this
one so many Americans looking for things
to do while stuck at home for some
interpretive amount of time we're about
to talk to barstools Dave Portnoy about
what he's been doing to stay busy but
first one popular product from the 80s
and 90s is making a comeback in fact
it's now sold out just about everywhere
proper suction is the key to getting
great-looking haircuts with no cleanup
[Music]
[Music]
people mocked it now you wonder why bar
stools Dave Portnoy has won he joins us
tonight Dave you look very the flow
buddy's been good for you what do you
say anything I have to ask you about
your purple pants about 15 people have
contacted me today and asked me to ask
you are you wearing purple trousers and
why you can see them there hopefully
we're doing this remote so hopefully you
could see that but yes I am wearing
purple sweatpants I just started wearing
them every day because what's the point
of changing pants if you're not going
outside and then I decided this would be
caught in my fight against Corona Corona
will not make me waist pants
they just won't so I'm gonna wear these
pairs pants I live one my purple sweat
pants till the quarantine is lifted the
bigger question is am i washing the
pants which occasionally I am but yeah I
just wear the same pants every single
day I'm glad one man is taking a stand
against this scourge so what else you
doing
with the pants on I'm day trading Tucker
so I've never done that before I let's
bet on sports courts are gone so I have
set up a little bell in my office 9:30 I
ring it and I go to work just day
trading the crap or the stock market I
took a financial beating because I think
you know a company pen national bought a
good portion of parcel sports well it
turns out this pandemic is not good for
the casino business because they're
closed
so I said on a day trade my way out of
this thing it's not working I have a fat
guy today that works for me and I asked
him every day what he likes and he gave
me a cheesecake factory and act that
they do well and they just said that
they're actually not gonna pay their
rent factory how much we know how long
this is going how much money do you
expect to lose day trading by the end of
it oh I'm trying to win I'm about even
I mean it's ABS inflows I'm firmly
convinced when the market is going down
there's people get rich when the market
is going up there's people get rich
trying to get the ebbs and flows and
then I got three million knuckleheads
saying I told you to do this I told you
to do that
and I'm just dependent on my fact iconi
balls
he says when lunchtime hits people get
hungry order Shake Shack and that's what
I invest in can't you just watch Netflix
like everyone else yeah here's my here's
my TV schedule I have that down as well
i watch one movie a day a new one and
then I'm watching the office over and
over just cycling through the seasons it
never gets old you know that sounds like
a pretty good schedule I gotta say
day-trading watching movies wearing
purple pants I don't know what's gonna
happen to this country I know where the
virus is going but I'm pretty sure Dave
port and I will emerge stronger from
this experience you've given us all
heart deport Mike thanks so much thanks
for having me